FIND REASONS WHY THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO STAY.
THEY ARE STONE COLD VICIOUS
KILLERS.
>> Jeanine: JOINING US IS
STRATEGIST TO PRESIDENT
PRESIDENT SEBASTIAN GORKA AND
THE GERALDO RIVERA.
I UNDERSTAND GERALDO, THAT WHAT
THE PRESIDENT SAID ABOUT MS 13
WAS IN REACTION TO WHAT SOMEONE
HAD SAID BEFORE ABOUT THE MS 13
GANG MEMBERS.
EVEN YOU, A SMART PERSON LIKE
YOU WERE CAUGHT OFF GUARD
THINKING THAT HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT EVERYONE AS ANIMALS.
TAKE IT BACK.
>> WELL, THE PRESIDENT'S REMARKS
WERE REREESED PIECEMEAL BY
PEOPLE CRITICIZING THE PRESIDENT
FOR USING HOT BUTTON WORDS LIKE
ANIMAL.
WHEN I FIRST READ IT WAS NOT IN
THE CONTEXT OF MS13.
I THOUGHT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
IMMIGRANTS AND THEN I HEARD FROM
SEAN AFTER I COMPLAINED.
NO, READ THE ENTIRE REMARKS.
I WAS NOT WORKING THAT DAY.
AND I READ THE CONTEXT.
AND I AMENDED MY REMARKLESS.
YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL.
BUT YOU ARE NOT DEMONIZING THE
ENTIRE GROUP AND THAT'S WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS SEIZED ON AND THE
PRESIDENT CREATES MORE PROBLEMS
FOR HIMSELF THAN WHAT HE'S
WORTH.
IN THINK EVERY EFFORT SHOULD BE
TO CRUSH MS 13.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
JUST LIKE THE BLOODS AND CRIPS
ARE A MENACE AND THE MAIF IIA
AND THE RUSSIAN MOB IS A MENACE.
THEY WANT THEM DEPORTED OR
BEHIND BARS.
WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL NOT TO
PAINT FOR A BROADBRUSH.
>> Jeanine: WHEN I WAS A JUDGE,
I SENTENCED SOMEONE.
A MURDER SENTENCE AND I CALLED
THE GUY AN ANIMAL AND HE
BELONGED TO'S CAGE.
I GOT A LOT OF HEAT FOR.
THAT I THINK THAT ONE.
REASONS THAT PEOPLE LOVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THAT HE IS
A STRAIGHT TALKER.
IF YOU TAKE A MACHETTO AND CUT
PEOPLE UP AND A BASEBALL BAT AND
YOU ARE A ANIMAL.
IN 2014 THERE WAS A BIG INFLUX
IN MATERIAL AMERICA.
THEY SAID I AM A LATIN KING AND
MS13 AND WE WERE LETTING THEM
IN, SHOULD WE HAVE?
>> LOOK, I AM DISAPPOINTED WITH
GERALDO'S NONAPOLOGY.
GERALDO, YOU MET THE PRESIDENT
AND HOW CAN YOU THINK FOR
A MILLISECOND THAT ALL
IMMIGRANTS IS ANIMALS.
HE IS MARRIED TO AN IMMIGRANT
AND THAT IS ABSURD.
IT IS NOT AN ACCIDENT.
NEW YORK TIME AND CBS HAD
HEADLINES THAT HE CALLED
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS ANIMALS.
THAT'S A LIE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE ANIMALS TALKING
ABOUT THE MS 13 GANG MEMBERS AND
THIS IS AN ORGANIZATION THAT ITS
NAME COMES FROM THE VIOLENT
INITIATION RITUAL TO GO THROUGH
TO BECOME A KILLER.
YEAH, JUDGE, IT IS AMAZING TO
HAVE A PRESIDENT THAT FINALLY
TALKS THE TRUTH AND THAT'S WHY
HE CONNECTS TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHO KNOW THESE PEOPLE ARE
KILLER AND ANIMALS.
>> Jeanine: SHOULD PRESIDENT
PRESIDENT HAVE LET THEM IN
KNOWING WHO THEY WERE.
TO BE A MEMBER OF MS 13 YOU HAVE
TO KILL SOMEBODY AND GENERALLY
RAIN SOMEONE AND THEN KILL THEM?
SHOULD THE PRESIDENT HAVE LET
THEM IN?
>> HISTORICALLY JUDGE.
WE HAVE TO TAKE THE STAGE.
>> Jeanine: NO, I AM NOT.
I AM ASKING YOU A QUESTION.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT MS 13.
IT WAS IDENTIFIED AS THE
MENACING ORGANIZATION RELATIVELY
RECENTLY IN 2004.
>> BALONEY, WHEN I WAS DAN I
KNEW THEY WERE ANIMALS.
AND NOW PRESIDENT OBAMA LETS
THEM IN AND SAID YOU HAVE TO LET
THEM IN.
>> THE PROBLEM IS.
LET ME FINISH MY SENTENCE.
THE PROBLEM WITH INFLAMMATORY
REMARKS LEAK DR. GORKA'S ATTACK
ON ME IS THAT IT OBSCURES THE
BIG ISSUE.
>> Jeanine: WHAT IS THAT?
>> PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT LAW AND
ORDER.
WEEPMENT THE FEDERAL, STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO USE EVERY
TOOL TO CRUSH THESE CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
THEY ARE ORGANIZED CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE NO PLACE
IN AMERICA SOCIETY IMMIGRANT OR
DOCUMENTS OR UNDOCUMENTS.
>> Jeanine: WHAT IS YOUR POINT?
>> ILLEGAL CITIZEN AND GANG
BANGERS HAVE TO BE CRUSHED AND
NO POINT IN AMERICAN SOCIETY.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT A TINE EP
SLIVER OF THE 11 MILLION ODD
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS.
>> YOU PAINT WITH A BRUSH.
>> THAT IS BALONEY.
>> YOU MAY NOT AGREE WITH ME.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAD THE OPENING TO
ATTACK THE PRESIDENT AND TAKING
HIM OUT OF CONTEXT.
YOU HAVE TO BE CARE:>> Jeanine:
THEY LIE ALL OF THE TIME.
>> JUST LIKE ITALIAN PEOPLE
PAINTED BY THE BROAD BUSH OFMENT
MAIF IA.
IT WAS A SIGMA AND THE MS 13,
EVERY RESPECTABLE LATINO IN THIS
COUNTRY WANTS MS 13 ERADICATED.
>> Jeanine: WE HAVE TO BE
STRAIGHT SHOOTERS.
AND GERALDO, I WANT TO FINISH
THIS.
THE TRUTH IS ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
AND IMMIGRANTS AND CHAMBER MADE
AND THE PERSON WAITING ON YOU.
THEY WANT THEM GONE AND SO LET'S
CALL THEM WHAT THEY CARE.
I DON'T CARE.
IT IS IT ABOUT TIME TO SAY THIS
IS RIGHT OR THIS IS WRONG AND
THIS IS LEGAL AND THIS IS
ILLEGAL.
>> I JUST WANT EVERYTHING TO
STOP BEING RIGHT, LEFT OR RED
AND BLUE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD
STAY UNIEMENTED.
LATINO FOR THE MOST PART WANT TO
BE HARD WORKING PART OF THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE RAPIST AND
MURDERERS.
>> AND THEY WORK HORR HARD AND
NO ONE IS LOOKING TO GET RID OF
THEM.
IT IS THE CRIMINAL AND AN